welcome to this video Carol crucero okay
yeah good are we what line maybe I can
try the side self I really have no idea
about it at least not something that i
will call knowledge even so we should
see to this is a move after a for age 6
hmm hmm can I go maybe I can just do
that without going age six in this
position yeah that should be shouldn't
that be in my favor I mean not like I'm
better but just a positive difference as
g6 feels more useful here then then h6
okay
does he want what is what this is what
is he going to do here is coming with 94
that could be an argument against this
young definitely that could be an
argument that g6 is weak but ok 94 I
might have nitric see 595 isn't that a
move right 595 I actually wanted to take
with the bishop first and then night xt5
but you can take with the bishop on your
form that's the problem
95 2893 no that's not working at all 95
95 21 Knight f6 check Wow now that's not
working either okay
that's unfortunate if all this is not
not going to work okay night xe5 is not
working Bishop g7 that's 96 what a bad
position and once I spent a long time
with figuring out how bad it is hmm I
don't know did he have to go e6
I'm not sure let's try to be quick and
maybe get the Queen's off
and yeah cheeks 25 something like that
I'm happy to to trade some stuff even
though it's maybe not the best challenge
in uation mostly because of the time
situation but it's not so bad one minute
50 is kind of okay and the position now
is good it's really good so can also
take maybe that's not bad okay so
whoopsie six no then check in 98 I can
go see form
TX b3 b2 yep wow really getting such a
strong counter take their also look a
one check we'll see promoting himself
and I don't get it chat I just promoting
him
white resides I'm just promoting at
least that's what he believes neither
form was still a top and well okay I'm a
piece of him so I was a very irritating
it was very irritating cheeks takes no
94 I can't check on your five I couldn't
really i didn't see how they would work
I can take rookie five I didn't see that
how that would work and i thought this
this this check seven okay this is good
for me i didn't see that one because of
the okay well that was difficult to see
now this and this is hanging and he
doesn't have a good move something like
this ship t6 and tea auntie gets killed
I only calculated up to this that I will
lose this on e5 but I also saw that this
Hanks but I didn't see route d1 didn't
see Ruby one okay yeah that makes whole
the whole white play a big Bluff
anything and this is not not good at all
but maybe it's so key and Angeles just
giving white a slide plus so at least it
seems that I'm not immediately exploding
yeah this I don't know who he could have
taken here
very nice that's a mistake am so this
this this this is given us the best move
by the comp but check that's not exactly
grade 25 check yeah that leads to a bad
end game now the engine wants to take
take here Rollie five interesting check
yeah Jim I'm just clearly better yeah
and the pawn is promoting at the engine
already seized minus 2 a.m. so i could
have taken e5 but i didn't calculate
that deep enough to really work it out
okay thanks for watching